losing a game like this you can just
see the agony on yan's face and it's
kind of a little bit disturbing in a
certain way so we've all got to pass on
our love to the poor guy um i think it
will be move 55
maybe i had a little uh a little
prediction on that that's what i'm going
to go for so i'm hoping for move 55 but
we'll just get a couple of other
people's impression on uh what's going
on and i got my good friend here blair
who came all the way from england to to
have a point and to also uh well just
watch some of the chess so uh so blair
um you're a big chess fan yourself and
uh how do you think the game's been so i
mean it's been very tough for yann yeah
so it's been an incredibly disappointing
day for yeah and the pontiac today
hasn't it i mean i think that game six
the epic battle in game six
i think it's taking its toll and and
he's just not been himself today at all
has he we've not seen any fight real
fight from him today just a
disappointing day all round for him yeah
yeah i i think that's what most people
are thinking i mean we're we're a lot of
us are happy for uh happy for magnus i
mean he's getting nearer to becoming
world champion i don't think it's
totally over there's a rest day there's
six games to go yan's got to go all in
with the rest of the game so he can
really try some crazy chess so i think
actually it's going to be more exciting
the games because you just got to throw
everything at him king scan bit whatever
you want what the hell just go for it so
we're gonna have great chess to come but
effectively at the moment the game is
over and magnus has got another uh great
win under his belt so um i i don't know
if we're gonna get a celebrationary beer
now or commit commiseration beer for yan
but uh it's come to that time of the day
and uh i don't know what you're feeling
back in the studio um uh happy and sad i
think is is the emotions we've got here
yeah yeah i guess that covers it simon
happy days for magnus but just
devastating for yana pomnyacci thanks so
much for that and i guess maybe the the
screaming and the celebration and the
good night will uh be coming very soon
maybe i move 55 as you predict it
and none of the players are right now
sitting by the board
i mean magnus is in the move
he's not here
what will happen when he comes back and
he comes back
well i i do predict that he will maybe
relocate the queen once more just to
control the black queen's checking
squares and i think he's just simply
i want to say playing with napoleon
because he knows that an abomination has
no chance it's just uh about
coordinating everything correctly and
then waiting for napoliyachi to
just uh extend his hand in resignation
yeah but i don't i don't think that uh
uh magnus will actually promote not
promote push one of his pawns
no and uh maybe we can just show this
the winning technique that yeah we're
both expecting here right now from
magnus uh he's just given a check to the
black king this was blocked by the black
pawn and now the move i'm expecting for
sure is actually to retreat the white
queen all the way back to the first rank
just to cover any checks along this rank
but also after a check on the diagonal
white's king now is super safe there's
no more checks for the rest of the game
and because the white queen is placed
behind a past pawn this passport is
simply going to motor up the board and
it's going to decide the game i think
black has no counter play here also the
white queen does cover this square which
is key because if black pushes the pawn
the white queen is always going to be
covering and can take this pawn at the
right moment so
some work to be done for magnus
potentially but if he steps back with
his queen i think this will cut out any
more checks and
also if the black queen ever just goes
back to block one pawn then remember
white has another one to push and
eventually the black queen will be
forced out of the way of magnus's pawns
so this is the move i'm expecting
personally
to retreat here i think that would make
sense of white's last move at least and
ivanka you mentioned probably not
expecting this one no maybe it's good as
well
yeah no reason to allow any checks
though along the first rank for example
if you push forward at least you have
some annoying calculation work to be
done now yeah you've got to work out
what happens
yeah exactly and you don't want to
immobilize your queen in order to block
the check so
much easier to
just play the move that you suggested
drop the queen back
and then get ready to push pawns yeah
drop the queen back hide the king in the
corner and then push beth and david
aboard the bnd pawns
looks relatively straightforward let's
go back to the world champion
is he about to make that move is he
going to retreat the white queen this is
a new tactic from him
raising his hand to make his move but
saying to himself look one more time
yeah possibly it's difficult to say
though
whether it's kind of an instinctive
thing or
whether it's a conscious decision
normally it looks like he's focusing so
okay there we go the queen move that we
indicated
but normally it's
i mean players i don't really do that on
purpose if it happens then it's purely
because i'm genuinely changing my mind
or doubting myself it's not a conscious
decision saying okay nope second thought
normally you do that with you know your
hands by your side or sitting on those
hands
but
yeah no pumping at you now if he doesn't
find any counter play you can give one
more check you can move the black king
he can move a black pawn but nothing's
going to change
it's hard to you know hard to give much
advice here for black yeah for napo
yes it is
and
should i tell the rest of my hikaru
promoting to a night story yes it was
against shakarya mama jarov
in a in a blitz game and so you know he
could have chosen to promote to a queen
to a bishop to a rook and uh shakira
mahmoud would have been forced to
capture that piece
because he chose to
very
flashly promote to a knight
this allowed shakira mahmoud to give
like a check with his rook and drive the
white king back
and then he captured the knight and the
funniest thing is ever is that it
actually became really difficult for
hikaru to defend what was an easily
drawn position
and he lost it
and afterwards sakurai gave this
it was interviewing like he couldn't
believe his eyes he said promote to a
queen promote her rook promote to
anything but a night
but i mean so good idea you know it's
it's great to be flashy but you gotta
calculate it properly so we've seen this
in um online chess of course you know
you choose which piece you want to
promote to how does it work in over the
world if you don't want to promote to
that extra queen that is beside the
board um normally by the time you make a
promotion knights have been traded off
the bishops have been traded off so you
can go and take the piece which has left
the board and put it on the board
uh
yeah i mean it's very rare to promote to
bishops rooks uh i must say bishops and
rooks the reason we nearly never see
promotions is because they do the same
job as a queen so you might as well
promote to a queen the rare times that
night promotions happen you normally do
have that night but if not i guess you
stop the clock you ask the arbiter can i
have a spare night
they'll go run off and get one for you
that would be an interesting situation
yes what you must not do is you must not
say you know must not promote the porn
and just leave it as a pawn oh because
and then
and then technically an illegal move
actually porn cannot be on the internet
of course
so if you do that you don't
take another piece and you click the
clock yeah illegal move it is an illegal
move
sometimes you lose the game if you make
an illegal move yeah
so uh yeah don't do that also for online
players i know a lot of our viewers
play a lot online
yeah don't necessarily have auto
promoter queen on the board just in case
you promote to a queen it might end in
stalemate or you promote to a queen and
it's not necessarily the best move
sometimes you want to promote to a
knight with a check
but then again if you don't have auto
promoter queen on if you have no time on
the clock then it takes annoyingly
several seconds to promote to that queen
and okay my prediction is not correct
it's not 42 moves i was secretly hoping
napoli actually might throw in the towel
there still close though still close
okay he gives a check the white queen
the white king sorry has to sidestep the
check but it's safe in the corner
no more checks
and
okay
nothing else to do the black pawn has to
push forward you need counter play in
queen end games you need to open up your
opponent's king that's why napoli
actually has pushed this pawn he wants
to actually give up this pawn he wants
to throw it down the board even further
in order to break up white structure
white's protection
uh in front of the white king yeah we
did see in that game six that magnus
eventually won the bar was all the way
up to like 60 i think even at a point a
hundred maybe yeah it's it's
it's only six only six so does that mean
there is hope or is it the computer that
is not
able to sort of
see this fully yeah i mean the computer
that we're using i think it has a
specific horizon maybe if the horizon
was deeper if we were running it on the
most powerful processes it would
probably say plus 100 or close right now
but uh yeah that means at least that
there's no win within the next 20 moves
or 25 moves or no force checkmate
because 100 means checkmate basically
checkmate within the next few moves
it shows that magnus can win but it's
not a force checkmate in 20 or 25. he
still needs to find a few accurate moves
first
of course he might win before the next
20 moves but
if
the problem actually defends correctly
he can fight for a bit longer well he
leaves again
a sign he's not
about to resign this game there is like
a tiny smidgen of hope here and that is
as david kind of indicated for black
just to
push that g pawn one square forward and
then the whole idea is that if the white
queen captures then the white queen is
kind of decoyed from the defense of the
king and if it's the poem that captures
then
then the idea is just simply to push
forward with your h-born and try to
remove the cover from white's king
yeah
unfortunately unfortunately for the
pontiac even if he does uh go for this
then after this trade yes the white king
is out in the open but white is three
pawns up and all of the three pawns are
defended by the white queen so oh wow
yeah i think this one's pretty hopeless
as well you can give one check here but
eventually the checks will dry up for
example i can already see a way to stop
the checks you can bring your queen
forward and after one more check you
just hide on the side of the board so
with three extra pawns it's pretty
straightforward uh but napoleon actually
he has to try something and he's hoping
that magnus just gets nervous about the
white king maybe being opened up
uh so for example if white does push
forward and this type of scenario where
after pawn takes pawn the black pawns
coming forward the white king not
entirely safe maybe maybe magnus just
slightly nervous here and also in this
line after i mentioned the pawn stepping
forward maybe black can create some
threats of checkmate uh a bit of a pin
here
this won't save the game but
uh at least it's putting the fear of
ghosts into magnus's mind
so i like the fact he's playing on the
pontiac despite breaking my prediction
challenge i like the fact he's at least
fighting now yeah before it's too late i
agree i agree um especially because i've
predicted 50 moves
so i'm getting close
and uh
yeah i'm quite inspired because your
line looked like it might last seven
moves
[Laughter]
and then whoa ten points in the back
sorry david i'm a bit competitive
that's all right well we know you are
because you're a top chess player and
what we've talked about today you're
going to be at top chess whereas you
need to be competitive yeah nothing
wrong with being competitive as long as
you're
respectful to other people sportsmanship
is important as well but of course
competition that's why we love sport
yeah
which is why it's nice that they have
these rooms where they can rest in
between because then maybe nepo can be
in there right now just get his
frustration out so that he can in a
respectful way resign at some point yeah
exactly and we should also mention it's
not disrespectful to play on it's within
the rules yeah so resignation
uh is fine sometimes if you're if you
know it's inevitable um if you want to
just escape and go and rest but you
don't have to why not play on well we
always hope they're going to play to
checkmate right exactly we want to see
it as fans yeah but what's really nice
is actually that uh napolita is playing
on is that we actually get to see the
technique that magnus uses in order to
score the full points is this
you know instructive something for
beginners to pay attention to right now
definitely with uh four pawns for minus
two for yan right because i mean we
could see we could have seen situations
where magnus was
really kind of like carefree just pushed
forward with his pawns but here we see
magnus take a very slow and steady
approach he's like well first of all i'm
gonna secure my pawns i'm gonna secure
my king i'm gonna try to control the
whole board and then and only then will
he think about advancing and rushing
forward with one of his pawns
yep it's always about control um i think
the other thing that when i was young i
used to do i used to commit some
mistakes in queen endings it was just
giving checks at any possible moment for
example magnus now he can bring the
white queen up and deliver check to the
black king but he doesn't need to do
that he remember his two pawns up he's
not going to win this game by checking
he's going to win this game by pushing
pawns so
just because you see a check doesn't
mean you have to go for it
and magnus i think they're about to push
his central pawn
and
okay he took his hand back but there we
go
there he comes that d-pawn is marching
finally he feels he has full control and
he's hoping that black's pawn push the
only remaining source of hope for
napolita is not going to lead anywhere
well they played now for four hours 44
moves could it also be that yon sort of
he wants this game to last as long as
possible because you don't want to lose
a quick game right no exactly
i've been there many times myself
sometimes i'll move 25 i'm completely
lost and then i was just like okay it
looks bad
it looks bad for the fans if they see a
quick defeat so okay here we go exactly
what we showed black gave up that pawn
to open up the white king
and uh black is currently three pawns
down wow
yeah at least the white king though less
safe than it used to be
and against some fear in the back of
magnus's mind
i mean there's no perpetual even if you
capture the pawn right yeah i think you
can take the pawn safely you can move
the white queen safely
it looks like magnus going for his queen
you can even push the white pawn safely
but there we go the white queen going as
close to the white king as possible
and resignation
it's over magnus carlsen is up by two
points in the world chess championship
match after eight games a devastating
and brutal loss for young
[Music]
[Music]
this